es ist ein zwiespältiger Auftritt des
CDU-Chefs gestern irgendwie zwischen
Attacke und Annäherung gleichermaßen für
die Annäherung steht der Gast an seiner
Seite der ur-grüne Ralf Füchs für die
Attacke Friedrich Merz selbst und der
geißelt wieder mal die Habeck
heizungspläne
dass die Grünen insbesondere mit Herrn
Harbeck das als von uns nicht
bestrittene Ziele versuchen mit einer
Methodik zu erreichen die einen großen
Teil der Bevölkerung vor den Kopf stößt
doch März adelt den politischen Gegner
den er gerade so bekämpft es ist seine
Art die Anschlussfähigkeit in das
liberale Milieu zu erhalten und der Gast
erkennt das durchaus an was der sagt
klingt ganz ähnlich wie sein Gastgeber
es reicht nicht sich als antiampel zu
profilieren als eine Partei die auch
konservativ ist nicht nur müssen sie ja
die Brücke schlagen zwischen
konservativen Grundbedürfnissen wie
Sicherheit und einer zeitstürmischen
Wandels doch wofür steht die CDU gerade
ist ein neues Grundsatzprogramm
tatsächlich hilfreich oder ist es nur
ein weiteres Papier Dutzende von Ideen
diskutiert man von einer Steuerreform
über ein soziales Pflichtjahr bis zum
Sprachtest für Vorschulkinder es ist
offenkundig dass wir die Bundestagswahl
deshalb verloren haben weil wir nicht
mehr gut genug waren und diesen Fehler
wollen wir jetzt wett machen ich glaube
es reicht nicht mehr aus nur in
Anführungsstrichen Regierungspartei zu
sein doch genau das ist offenbar immer
noch die Wahrnehmung irgendwie doch
Regierungspartei zu sein selbst wenn man
in der Opposition ist und dabei dann
gemeinsame Sache zu machen mit den
Grünen und der SPD die CDU wird eben
nicht als Alternative wahrgenommen nicht
zur Alternative die sich AFD und nicht
zur Ampel
in einer CDU internen Analyse zählt man
bis dato 188 Initiativen der Regierung
wir haben 108 Initiativen zugestimmt die
hohe Zahl hat uns selbst überrascht
schreibt man die CDU leidet an dieser
Selbstanalyse leidet an der
ausbleibenden Zustimmung mehr als 30%
wollen es zur Zeit einfach nicht werden
und die Unzufriedenheit wächst so
mancher versucht mit Härter Rhetorik den
Erfolg zu erzwingen und kann sich durch
den Parteichef ermutigt fühlen wir
müssen auch in der Lage sein mal
Probleme zu adressieren auch mal mit
Formulierungen die nicht jedem gefallen
und das ist dann nicht gleich rechts und
das ist dann auch nicht gleich
rassistisch und das ist vor allen Dingen
nicht irgendwo AFD sprechen es sind die
Stilfragen die die alten Gräben
aufreißen konservativere gegen
liberaleere aktive Ministerpräsidenten
gegen ehemalige Anti Gendern Pascha
Energie Stasi ist das noch CDU oder
schon AFD sprechen
Daniel Günther beklagt man solle den
Leuten halt keinen Scheiß erzählen es
bringt uns gar nichts wenn wir über so
einen Mist diskutieren Roland kocht
dagegen verurteilt taktisches schweigen
und die emotionalen tabutonen seiner
Partei es geht darum entsprachlich
zuzuspitzen um damit eben auch Menschen
aufmerksam zu machen die vom
Studierzimmer bis zum Stammtisch
Menschen mitnimmt wir brauchen mehr
Bürger Nähe mehr vor Ort sein mehr mit
den Menschen auf Augenhöhe sprechen und
das bringt uns weiter als die ein oder
andere Überzeichnung die man sicherlich
in der politischen Debatte braucht die
aber manchmal mehr abgrenzt und
ausgrenzt und noch eine Debatte bricht
über den cdu-parteiischer Verein denn
auch die persönlichen Werte von
Friedrich Merz sind schlecht da reicht
schon die Forderung des Chefs des
größten Landesverbandes an der
Kanzlerkandidaten Auswahl beteiligt zu
werden um daraus eine Anmeldung zur
Kandidatur zu lesen auch ein Symptom
einer zutiefst ratlosen Partei
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der
Vorsitzende der CDU guten Tag Herr März
guten Tag Herr Gold das neue
Politbarometer zeigt zwar ein Negativ
Rekord für die Ampel aber auch einer
unionsgeführten Regierung traut die
Mehrheit der Menschen nicht mehr zu
woran fehlt es ihrer Partei oder ihn
wir waren 16 Jahre in der Regierung und
jetzt sind wir seit rund 16 Monaten in
der Opposition und die CDU ist auf dem
Weg noch einmal ihre Positionen zu
überprüfen noch einmal wirklich
durchzulüften sich zu erneuern das geht
nicht über Nacht und da brauchen wir
auch ein bisschen strategische Geduld
und ich werde mich deswegen von dieser
Nervosität überhaupt nicht anstecken
lassen wir gehen unseren Weg sehr
konsequent und das was wir am Freitag
und am Samstag in Berlin getan haben war
ein großer Schritt nach vorne und ich
kann übrigens von dieser totalen
Verunsicherung die Kollege da gerade
berichtet hat nicht spüren im Gegenteil
es gibt eine wirkliche Aufbruchstimmung
jedenfalls bei denen die bei uns aktiv
mitgearbeitet und mit diskutiert haben
und das waren viele aber diese
Aufbruchstimmung die nimmt sich ja Zeit
die ampelkriselt wie nie die AFD hat
enorm Zulauf des CDU-Programm soll aber
erst im nächsten Jahr fertig werden
müssen Sie diesen Prozess nicht extrem
beschleunigen damit die Menschen wissen
was sie von der Union erwarten haben
Teile des Programms haben wir ja schon
verabschiedet schon im letzten Jahr in
Hannover wir haben am Freitag auf
unserem kleinen Bundesparteitag ein sehr
umfassenden Antrag zur friedens- und
freiheitspolitik verabschiedet wir haben
uns intensiv auf vielen Seiten mit
Bildungspolitik und
Familienpolitik befasst also die
Positionen werden nach und nach Klara
aber der Rest kommt erst nächstes Jahr
nein so ein Prozess braucht seine Zeit
und wenn Sie
eine Partei wirklich erneuern wollen
dann geht das nicht über Nacht wir
arbeiten nicht mit der Brechstange
sondern wir arbeiten mit Sorgfalt auf
ihrem Programm Convent hat nicht zuletzt
die eisschnellläuferin Claudia Pechstein
klare Kante gezeigt der Auftritt schlägt
jetzt hohe Wellen weil Pechstein in
Polizeiuniform auftrat was sagen sie zu
auftritt und zu Kritik
also der Auftritt war brillant und
Claudia Pechstein hat uns noch mal aus
ihrer Erfahrung gesagt wie wichtig Sport
Vereine Breitensport sind und ehrlich
gesagt das interessiert mich wirklich
das Äußere interessiert mich nicht es
interessiert mich was jemand zu sagen
hat und Claudia Pechstein hat wie viele
andere die auch da waren uns was zu
sagen und darauf haben wir geachtet und
da haben wir zugehört also den Inhalt
fanden sie großartig und der die Uniform
ist kein Problem also sie können auch an
diesem Beispiel schon sehen über welche
Äußerlichkeiten wir da diskutieren der
Inhalt interessiert mich und der war
wirklich interessant und der hat uns
auch ein Stück motiviert in diese
Richtung weiter zu arbeiten
schauen wir mal auf ein anderes Thema
wenn der demokratisch gewählte
bayerische Vize Ministerpräsident
eiwanger Lautstärke auf einer Demo
fordert Zitat jetzt ist der Punkt
erreicht wo endlich die schweigende
große Mehrheit dieses Landes sich die
Demokratie wieder zurückholen muss
verlangt das nicht nach einer Reaktion
von Ihnen oder der CSU das ist ja
immerhin der Koalitionspartner ihrer
Schwesterpartei
ich habe darauf reagiert am Freitag sehr
klar uns ja deutlich in meiner Rede auf
dem kleinen Bundesparteitag der CDU und
habe gesagt in Deutschland muss ich
niemand die Demokratie zurückholen
allein die Existenz der Opposition
nämlich jetzt von uns ist Beweis genug
dass wir Demokratie in Deutschland haben
das ist nicht unser Sprachgebrauch und
den mache ich mir auch nicht zu eigen
wir haben es eben den Beitrag ja schon
gesehen Ministerpräsident Hendrik wüst
hat auf die Frage ob er eine
Kanzlerkandidatur anstrebe geantwortet
ich zitiere meine Aufgaben liegen
aktuell in Nordrhein-Westfalen da wurde
doch ein Scheunentor zu einer künftigen
Kandidatur weit aufgestoßen mit Ihrer
Unterstützung
schauen Sie wir haben eine Entscheidung
im Spätsommer 2024 zu treffen und bis
dahin befassen wir uns nicht mit
Personalspekulationen sondern mit Themen
und die Themen werden von einer großen
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung
bestimmt in ganz Deutschland übrigens
auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen wenn wir
heute in Nordrhein-Westfalen
Landtagswahlen hätten wäre die AFD fast
so stark wie im Bund die Unzufriedenheit
auch in den Ländern auch leider in
Nordrhein-Westfalen aus dem ich ja komme
mit der Landesregierung ist fast genauso
groß wie die mit der Bundesregierung und
das zeigt uns doch eines wir haben es
mit einer ich habe so ausgedrückt mit
einer krisenhaften Zuspitzung in unserer
Demokratie zu tun an Unzufriedenheit
Besorgnis Frust und teilweise wirklich
Angst und deswegen finde ich sollte man
solche Menschen die da am Vorgehen am
vorletzten Samstag in Erding
demonstriert haben nicht gleich alle in
die rechte Ecke bringen wenn man das tut
dann sind nie irgendwann da ich finde
man muss diese Menschen die da so
eindrucksvoll demonstriert haben ernst
nehmen da mögen ein paar Querdenker
dabei gewesen sein aber die ganz
überwiegende Zahl und ich habe mir das
angeschaut ich habe mit den
Organisatoren gesprochen die ganz
überwiegende Zahl derer die da auf
diesem Tag demonstriert haben sind
ernstzunehmende Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aus der Mitte unserer Gesellschaft und
wenn wir die nicht mehr ernst nehmen
dann sind wir mit daran beteiligt dass
wir noch eine größere Zuspitzung links
und rechts bekommen ich möchte das nicht
und ich möchte die CDU da positionieren
wo die Sorgen der Menschen sind wir
wollen sie aufnehmen annehmen und in
vernünftige Politik umsetzen und das ist
glaube ich die wichtigste Aufgabe die
wir heute in unserer Zeit gekommen ich
danke Ihnen für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen sehr